女の子と一緒に朝おきたい
ダブル社長で女の子とはさん痛いんですよあの皆さん youtube の動画で女性
e to bar よく上げている morning routine ps わかり
ますか女の子の morning routine 動画なのでもう山たん生誕生だっ
たらみんみたいと思うんですよ買ってそんな女の子の朝なんてなんか見ちゃダメな気が
するんですけどその日で玲奈って言われたらもうから見ますよ
a
もちろんです喜んでパターンの大木邸からその仕事に行くなるとか朝登校する前までの
粉が洗顔とか朝ごはんとかあったか色々なもの朝の5連の動きを動画にしてるのが良く
際にあるんですけどもあの場にいたいですはじめも女性ユーチューバーの
morning routine の中にいたい
でも
bai
ああああああああ
女性ユ千葉 morning routine の中に男の人がいることだってないん
ですよ
でも誤解たい実際にその場にいるのは無理だと思うんであの自分でなんとか合成して
ですね女性ユーチューバーの morning routine 動画に映り込んで
映像を見るだけでもた僕うれしくなるんですよ
オレはあの綺麗な挑戦ユーチューバー morning routine の朝一緒に
おはようって感じで起きた
てそのまま一緒に歯磨き今でしょみたいなこと
頭で妄想できるねそれで今日はですね何度も後でもいいんで除染ユーチューバーの
morning routine ゾーンに僕も一緒に行って一緒に朝を迎えればいい
なと思っております合成でもいいです
一緒に朝を迎えましょうということでですねあの結城リナさんから許可を頂けましたの
で行き里奈さんの
オーニングブーティん動画
ご一緒させていただきます悪いね動画だから仕方ないんだよ
悪いでは以降1滴の akb さんが morning routine 童顔って
鬼没連携しましょう
音響曲名見えた b てみるはもう自分の居場所を見つけました
me
wh
[音楽]
h 2
ええええう
夢すぎて声が出ないんですけどね
w イェイ
uh
ame
me
闇後知恵感じでなきゃいけないんですよ終わります
ブーツ
ん
tame
[音楽]
顔を洗い終わったのでスキンケアをしていきたいとおもいます
東京はまず最初に落ちる州の導入化粧液をつけています
こういう聖堂の泥を使っていきます
来たら次に皮膚科でもらった薬を塗っていきますきっと肌れる日よって多くのです
薬を塗り終わったら乳液を塗っていきます
[音楽]
きたら歯を磨いていきます品以外できますと言うのかって
nome
いいいい
ただ今からこの髪の毛は村して整えていきます
[拍手]
ran
2者 f していきたいとおもいます
&いっしょ塗りが来たをオークス馬でグルグル回しながらその下の向きに合わせてメモ
google
宮骨といいらしいです
[音楽]
4分
せない土地へ行って生命いるでないかもしれん全部で受けと煌ツインも勢9
この吹いて急がないと
昨年30今日もないかは頑張りますじゃあん
この間性に行ったときに買った明太フランスの主武器中
いうを6時に出していく
付9品
new
ちょっとねトースト入れる c ように間違えてるブロボタンを押してなかったんだな
だけ取れてなかったんですけど今美味しいそうに焼けています google と
プロマリード近昨日の残り物のメッセージとピーマンを与えて終わり
[音楽]
薄桜鬼てないんですけれども
それでご飯を食べます
いけない
も朝はパン派ですねぇー
どんどん辛くなって行ってみたぞ
嘘でしたよしそれ片付け yeah
持ってません
nook 用品も獲りへ行っぷいがで見ると思う
もう決めた深いスカートに何かシャツでいきましょうということで着替えたのでいこう
と思い外す vip ってないけどこれでまあ出ようと思いますまたまたしてますが
だいたい朝はこんな感じです
儒教の動画を超えでおいてい
あっ最後までご視聴ありがとうございましたぜひ高評価宜しくお願いしますそれでを
バイバーイ
虚しいな
[音楽]
me
うううう
car
あっはぁ